as we support the people of ukraine we
must also
shore up our shared resilience both to
protect our people and our values
these are nothing more
than defensive measures which have been
the essence of nato for more than 70
years and i want to be crystal clear
finally on that point uh we will not
fight russian forces in ukraine and our
reinforcements like these reinforcements
here in tapa are firmly within the
borders of nato members and they are
profoundly the right thing to do nato
needs a forward defense strategy
nato should be
prepared to defend the most vulnerable
part of nato which is the baltic
countries
and this includes on land
establishing permanent increased forward
presence
in air establishing a credible
defense posture
and a sense of urgency in developing
nato's upgraded defense
plan
ukraine should be given a very clear
signal to join the eu
the security of ukraine is the security
of europe although there is no direct
military threat at our borders
nato must take a leap now and adopt
rapidly to the new security situation
nato is a defensive alliance
we do not seek conflict with russia
our message to president putin is
stop the war
pull out all your forces from ukraine
and engage in good faith in diplomatic
efforts
the world stands with ukraine in calling
for peace if it reminds me if anything
if you remember the shelling of sarajevo
uh market uh by uh by the serbs the
shelling of of innocent people in bosnia
it has that feel to me of an atrocity
committed deliberately against a
civilian center if vladimir putin thinks
he's going to push nato back uh by what
he's doing he's gravely mistaken this
will end up with uh with a fortified and
strengthened uh nato uh on his on on his
western uh flank uh he'll have more nato
not less nato